at this time i want to introduce the
gentleman behind the scenes of kill your
darlings uh director co-writer producer
john croquetas and co-writer austin bunn
hello
good morning everybody
and as usual if you have a question just
raise your hand is that one here in the
front
so do we have mics
um what was the division of creative
responsibility between you two on the
scripts i mean did one of you write the
david scenes and the other one wrote the
i'm joking but
that would have been interesting uh well
start with the inception
so
i mean probably like a lot of people in
this room i discovered the beats in
college
i used to go to the campus bookstore and
just track down the poetry collection
find alan's books and read them like
they were some secret like some
you know transmission from the future
version of myself because i'm a i was a
closeted young creative writer from new
jersey so alan ginsberg's work meant the
world to me
and uh
so i had this really strong connection
with allen and the beat biographies and
the beat history i read a lot of the bat
catalog and i come to john with the idea
so in terms of the division of
responsibility i would say like really
what i would write the first draft and
then john would come in and the thing
about john is you'll soon learn you
wanted to raise the emotional decibel
level in every scene i mean john is one
of the most ribbing the most vital and
least how to put it like a geographic
um version of this story we didn't want
to take the beats greatness as a given
so john sort of demanded that we write a
really emotional rollercoaster and so
that's and so then we just went back and
forth john talks about it as the postal
service like the banned version of
producing a script so emailing back and
forth constantly we were living in
different cities at the time i was at
the university of iowa's writers
workshop as a graduate student and john
was in new york finishing film school
austin wanted to do this as a play first
he was a playwright and a short story
writer of some renown and we're college
roommates and we shared ideas with each
other as college roommates and good
friends do but i of course started
seeing the movie version in the back of
my head
and i just got out of nyu film school
and started convincing him that the play
would be really flat and undramatic but
as a movie
this would be amazing
but i would say
i'm the structure guy i think coming
from nyu's film program i'm very
traditionalist in terms of cindy lumet's
find your spine and austin is really
wonderful with character and dialogue if
anything he's on a like religious
crusade against ex
expository dialogue and i would write
these three you know paragraph
monologues for each character expressing
their emotion like that scene where
jennifer jason lee finally turns to
allen to give him advice you know i had
the two-page monologue version and
austin cross it all out
and wrote the line that's in the movie
the most important thing your father
ever did was fail me
which said everything
so kind of playing off of that um since
the story it's also very visual too it
echoes the beats energy and such how did
you go about creating that look with
reed the cinematographer because it's
stunning
thank you so much and i'm so proud of
what reid brought to this film
i started off originally the movie set
in 1944 and it's a murder story and even
in the writing process i looked up and
saw that double indemnity won best
picture that year
and it was the year of laura and gilda
and all these great american film noirs
so i said why don't we incorporate this
even into the fabric of the movie and
start with the jail scene and a place of
heightened tension flash back to more
innocent times and then build again to
see whether or not these characters can
escape or not escape their fate and so i
started looking at noir stylings first
but i thought an academic recreation of
film noir who needs to see that
and again going back to spine and theme
i thought what this piece was really
about was young people finding their
voice so what about going from
conformity
you know the row houses of new jersey
the pillars of colombia to
non-conformity
and of course where film noir went in
the hands of the french was the new wave
so i thought okay well let's start off
with these controlled composed
expressionistic lit piece you know
uh shots
and then as the boys go down the rabbit
hole together let's take the camera off
the tripod
let's get some jazzier free you know
freeform styling so i made this book of
the 1940s i had learned that only for
the i the ice storm
did a 50-page book on the 1970s with
colors fonts uh important historical
events you name it so i did that with
the 1940s and then gave it to reid
now the great thing is that i've learned
on this this is my first film
is you can do all the academic treatises
you want but then you hire great people
and she saw the gold place goal posts
rather of what i wanted and then she
showed me jean-pierre melville's films
she showed me films that meant a lot to
her
and then what kind of what i wanted
filter through her own imagination and
what i'm amazed by specifically on her
work is we did this movie in 24 days
each scene was done in two hours or less
and the fact that she has the instincts
to be like a documentary camera person
but yet is able to light like that at
the same time
and then just lastly we wanted to make
sure this film felt relevant and
contemporary today and not just like a
dated period piece we never wanted this
even from the writing phase to be a
traditional biopic the greatest version
of their life
it was looking at
ryan mcginley photographs and youth you
know contemporary counterculture young
images of today and then finding what
connected them to the 1940s what was
resident encounter culture then and
today at the same time
question back then
hi ryan rojas intimacy i was just
wondering um oh first of all
congratulations if i can call you a
first time director just for this film
um thank you really fantastic um i'd
like to know
what was the direction that you were
giving your actors as far as we were
talking earlier with with them and they
were saying that you know sometimes you
pull them aside and for more dramatic
scenes but was there something like a
consciousness that you went into to
direct the film and how to
and how to direct the the actors or was
there any kind of specific notes that
you'd given them to kind of recreate
this specific tone
you know
here's the embarrassing story austin and
i actually met freshman year because we
were both acting in a production at yale
of the line in winter
neither of us were the greatest actor of
the actors in the world which is i think
why we went into writing and directing
um i think leggings looked better on you
than they do
that's what i would say about that
but i trained as an actor as an
undergraduate and you know what you
learn is that each actor has their own
method and their way of it's whatever it
takes for them to get the emotions to
the surface and so when i met with each
actor that i cast i would just simply
ask them have you trained you know how
do you like to work and what don't you
like
and you know and like michael c hall
gave me one of the greatest lessons in
directing what jesus said if you
if i'm not doing if i'm what i'm doing
is not making you happy
don't tell me that because that'll make
me self-conscious and it'll make me
think about what i'm doing just tell me
to add whatever you want to what i'm
doing
and that's just a great lesson for life
um
daniel dan and i when we were working
together we spent time before production
he was so generous and hard working on
this
he wanted to approach this like it was
his first film which was very poignant
to me
and i said would you like to try
learning a new method and approaching
acting in a different style and he said
absolutely so with dan
he's so bright and in his head and you
know for the really for the
intellectuals meisner works really well
and focusing your action what you're
trying to do on the other characters in
the scene
dane had trained extensively and for
dane
what he does is creates a bible for the
character
and does tons of research before
production
and then he burns it
and kind of becomes and starts really
becoming the character on set ben foster
has something i've never seen another
actor do
which is
once we've basically got the scene up on
its feet
he goes and he does the blocking of the
scene by himself in the location several
times he calls it the dance because once
he's memorized the dance and knows the
physicality i need to pick up the fork
here i need to put it down there he
doesn't have to think about it anymore
and that's completely freeing to him so
it's like cooking this huge seven course
meal where you have to get every you
know thing done at exactly the right
time but every plate needs a little bit
of love in a different way
and so to me what i'm obviously i love
working with actors to me the greatest
thing was being able to get this dream
cast and then just to work with them to
find how
they like to work and what got the best
out of them can i just add really
quickly that john you had a really
intuitive idea which was to keep the
actors from reading past this point in
the biographies so none of the actors
came in burdened by the mythology of who
these guys would become they were just
19 year old kids
so i think that was really smart and it
released the actors from having to play
later decisions in their lives the kinds
of writers they would become they just
got to be young people and that that was
a great relief i think for them yeah and
for us too as writers i mean we were
like oh my god we're tackling the beats
yeah are we going to forgive us our gods
forgive us but then you know like i had
a talk with jack houston once when we we
he and i share the same moment oh my god
i'm directing you as jack here we're
like no
you are jack who is a college student
on a football scholarship who hates the
other jocks who just wrote a book he
thinks it might be completely trite and
he just wants to get out of college and
have some real life experience join the
war so he can have real material to
write his next book that's who you are
and that just liberated all of us
when writing the script how much are you
tied to the truth and how much are you
allowed to take creative license we did
so much research for this i mean we
thought we had to and i think part of it
is our academic background yeah because
there's so much in the biographies i
mean there's so many biographies rather
of them out there but then also we would
find different accounts online from
example from david cameron's friends who
said that that relationship between him
and lucian
was never portrayed accurately
and that lucian actually kept coming
back to david and david was asking him
to end the relationship
and then we may have
broken into jack kerouac's college
apartment together
until somebody let us in but what's
interesting is columbia students were
living there they had no idea that they
were in jack kerouac's apartment
so we physically went to all of the
locations in which this movie took place
and that just helped inform our writing
process as well getting to be able to
visualize the actual spaces
after that you know i went to stanford
university to the allen ginsberg
archives
and there's just
it wasn't about
the lack of material out there if
anything it was about making sure that
we really just focused on this who they
were up until the point in which the
movie takes place
and just to add to that i would say that
um i think
the people that i know that have seen
the film have been really surprised at
how much is actually totally accurate
like the day after the murder alan
ginsberg went to the west end bar
you always hurt the one you love was
playing on the jukebox and he wrote the
poem that ends the film i mean it ends i
am a poet that is a lion from august
20th 1944. so we worked really hard to
weave it in but like john was saying
before we didn't want to do the dutiful
stuffy um every box checked kind of
biopic that that had been around for a
while we wanted to do something that
felt more like in line with the spirit
of the beast that was more
you know specific and honest and
transgressive
and i hope we got there
right here um
after watching this film i i think
there's many um
there's many things that the audience
can get out of and different uh emotions
that the audience can get out of this
did you guys have a goal a specific goal
of what you wanted to portray and what
you wanted the audience to leave with
either of the time or the characters
themselves
what i want the audience to leave with
is that feeling when we were 18 and 19
years old just like these guys were in
the movie
when everything seemed possible and you
knew that you had something important to
say about with your life that you want
to do something different and unique
not just what your parents taught you
not just what school taught you but you
wanted to leave your mark on the world
the fact that after these after the
movie these guys actually did it and
created you know the greatest counter
culture movement of the 20th century is
amazing
but if this you know i've had plenty of
people come up to me after seeing the
movie and said this movie made me want
to be a better writer or this movie made
me want to go back and start playing
music again that to me means everything
you mean that's ultimately deep in my
heart why i wanted to make this movie
and to think that that change
the pivot point was this murder i mean
the idea that i loved alan ginsberg for
his openness and his honesty and to
think at one point in his life he was
called upon to defend his best friend in
an honor slaying of a known homosexual
the very thing that like ginsburg went
on in his life to just defy and
radically um
create change about the idea of you know
being in the closet and the shame around
that issue so that contradiction was
really exciting to us dramatically
you know this movie took
from the time that we started talking
about this until the time that we're
getting that chance to be with you all
today
over 10 years to make
and
austin's right you know
when i really think about it the thing
that kept me going and kept me wanting
to tell the story i'd say that there
needs to be something that pisses me off
at night
the fact that in 1944 you could
literally get away with murder by
portraying your victim as a homosexual
that pissed me off to no end and this
isn't a political movie and it's one
scene and it's obviously what informed
houston car got away with murder
but for me that was the thing that kept
me up all night that said no i have to
tell the story
right here
i'm high i'm andrew blumenthal from
create a screenwriting magazine um so
you talked about the uh evolving visual
aesthetic going from the sort of rigid
row houses to the more flowing you know
off the tripod stuff but there's also a
melange of different musical styles you
had
jazz you had some contemporary like
percussive stuff when they're you know
running around through the library and
then there's some classical piano and
you know i know obviously
in a practical sense you were filming
the jazz stuff but did you envision the
different musical styles
were you involved with the sound mixing
and experimentation with all of all of
that
you know i originally wrote in this
remember my 50 page book because i'm
such a nerd and my academic treatise
that i wanted a bebop jazz score similar
to miles davis's score for louis miles
elevator to the gallows because bebop
the transition from swing to bebop at
this time was exactly what these guys
wanted to do with words go from
rhythms one two three to exploding them
into something beautiful
my music supervisor randall poster said
to me john put down your academic
treatise put down your paper go make
your movie
your child's gonna start becoming
the person that he or she wants to be
so i went and i made my movie and then i
put jazz music on the film and it didn't
work at all
and then i went and did only period
accurate music and it felt like woody
allen's radio days
which is a great movie but it's not the
young rebellious movie about being 19
and wanting to change the world that we
wanted to make so i actually went back
to the playlists that austin and i used
while writing this movie
and i used sigur ross i used the lead
singer's soul album yancy's album
stuff that was timeless but for
contemporary and it brought the music to
and brought the movie to life
and then i realized that nico muley the
composer had arranged all of those
albums and worked with grizzly bear and
bjork and other people that we were
using as temp track
and so we got the movie to nico and just
thankfully he loved it
so now that i knew i had contemporary
music in a period film
then we get to that high sequence
i had heist fury music on it it was so
corny
the sequence didn't work it didn't have
any stakes to it
and i can academically tell you well
yeah the beats come on they led to the
hippies which led to the punks and the
punks led to kurt cobain in the 90s
working with burrows in their history
with independent alternative music but
the truth is well i can intellectualize
it you go with what's visceral and what
feels honest and true to you and when i
put that track i just stuck my phone
into the computer played that track it
brought the scene to life and it gave it
the kind of energy and rebelliousness of
the spirit of the movie that we had been
wanting to write you know and hadn't
been working on for so long
so it kind of that of that evolved too
you know i think for me the biggest
lesson from making my first film is do
all your homework do all your research
know what you're doing
but then don't be afraid to get out of
the way if your movie starts telling you
what it should be doing and none of the
different styles of flash they seem to
have thank you it makes sense you know
further
further context so great question
first of all brilliant job guys
absolutely brilliant
in taking a look at the construct of the
script itself
you've got different dialogue beats that
hit and most notably
with your incorporation of recitations
by yates henry miller and whatnot how
did you decide
what to put in and then how did you work
with the actors in establishing the
cadence and the elocution on those
because your pentameter is totally
different than the rest of the structure
uh what a great question
um so well if anybody if you know any of
the beat history this new vision was
real for them and they've written
volumes about it and none of which makes
any sense that we could we could really
make we couldn't make head details
do you all remember your journals when
you were 20 years old of those
conversations you had at three in the
morning with other college students
we got to read their version of it and
there's a reason that we hide all of our
journals and don't let them see the
light of day it was challenging um but
so uh with the uninhibited uncensored
expression of the self that's actually
an incredible quote directly from the
ginsburg um nuvision manifesto so in
some ways we knew we had to distill some
of that material from the ginsburg
journals to help make the argument for
the how valuable this manifesto was and
the irony honestly of what transpires in
the plot right which is the very thing
that he's alan's called to do is create
this um censored version of history so
uh but in terms of the poetry itself
really challenging because we all know
they're movies about poets and writers
when recitations happen and they're
really flat and they can be corny and
they're the time you tune out of the
movie and you're like okay i'm waiting
for the poetry to end um specifically i
think of alan's first poem that happens
on the boat we um we were really
challenged to kind of find a poem that
would speak to audiences but was
genuinely an alan ginsberg poem written
in his voice uh and his early work is
quite rough and honest and burdened by
trying to impress his dad and impress
his professors
and so what we had to do was really
channel alan
and
when john had the concept of this isn't
a poem that he's just reading to impress
people it's a poem he's reading to
lucian car
and the audience knows that you know
that and lucian finds it out on that
boat at that moment and that really
allowed me gave me permission to kind of
rethink what the poem was going to do
and how the how we'd make it and so we
came upon the method of allen's very own
method which was kind of magpie stealing
from the american vernacular and going
out and finding common speech um and
repurposing it um creating this kind of
whitman-esque inclusion so you hear in
the poem things that you've already
heard in the film just like ginsburg did
himself so
things like allen in wonderland is
reworked in the poem um unbloomed
stalwart is the very thing that david
said to him in the party so we're kind
of hopefully paying off not just a poem
that's emotionally powerful but also
something of the method that pittsburgh
would use for the rest of his life
and radcliffe is such a hard worker we
would he gave me while he was on
broadway doing a musical we would meet
once a week for two months before even
pre-production rehearsal began to work
on the accent and to work together and
so i have on my iphone him reading how
and we look for though we didn't look at
the later recordings we looked at the
earliest vocal recordings possible of
allen ginsberg to make sure that we were
capturing the voice of who we'd become
but his voice at that time and what his
reading voice was like and then to be
honest it's just really telling the
actor don't you're not performing a poem
you are letting lucian know that he is
loved with this poem and that you love
him and that you can see inside him and
it's playing the emotion underneath the
poem
which was the direction
good time for one more question
what does it do for you when
um
the all of the main characters are gay
uh because normally
you've got the female characters who can
be a love interest but they're not going
to be
a rival they're not going to be they
have
usually even now
in films and in life
there's a
separate role whereas if you're all the
same gender you can all be anything to
each other
i'm sorry you're looking at me like that
made no sense
well i think this is a movie of every
character discovering
what their sexuality is gay straight bi
all over the place and more importantly
whether or not they're worthy of being
loved
you know and i
i personally don't know a flushing car
was straight or gay and to me it's
irrelevant because i've seen this
relationship play out amongst gay people
that i know so many times where an older
man who is gay and a younger man of
questionable sexuality develops such a
close bond and you know the stereotype i
think would be is that the younger man
had an absent father figure or finds the
older man's confidence and just the care
and nurturing
qualities of them very attractive
and
what happens though is those two get so
intimate that ultimately there's nowhere
else to take the relationship but sexual
and when that happens
then the power position in that
relationship twists
and the younger man suddenly realizes
that he holds the power because he's the
sexually desired one
and that's where a lot of conflict
ensues you know whatever you read about
that relationship between lucian and
david you know using contemporary terms
everyone knew it they were codependent
everyone knew it was toxic and badly
nobody knew it was going to end in
murder and let me just say quickly too i
think a lot of the biopics we see are
kind of denatured of their sexual
qualities and the edginess of the
relationships in them and so i think we
were trying to do something that
restored some of that ambiguity
lust desire confusion that is genuinely
in the beats history so it wasn't like
we were that was not we were not making
that up
well again congratulations thank you
guys so much
you